[Music]
one thing we've learned in our work is
that human beings have a tendency to see
patterns make inferences and judgments
and draw conclusions quite quickly from
just a little bit of data this is an
important skill it allows us to make
thoughtful inferences and predictions
but it can also lead to bad or
misinformed judgments when we're too
quick to draw inferences from a small
amount of data in our work with schools
we have found that a mental model called
the ladder of inference is especially
useful in helping educators resist this
tendency and stay focused on the
evidence the ladder of inference was
first developed by business theorist
Chris arduous and popularized by Peter
Sangay and colleagues in a book called
the fifth discipline the art and
practice of the learning organization
the ladder of inference is a metaphor
organized around how we as humans tend
to make patterns about what we see in
the world
whenever I perceive something I first
select some data to focus on then I add
some interpretation draw conclusions and
finally take actions the actions I take
then influence what kind of data I
collect next and for that reason it can
be very dangerous to go up the ladder
too quickly at data wise we like to use
this model to help each other maintain a
relentless focus on evidence when we
hear somebody add interpretations or
draw conclusions too quickly we try to
use phrases like that statement is
pretty high up on the ladder what
evidence are you using or we're all
making a lot of interpretations here
let's try to go back down that ladder
and talk first about the evidence there
might be a good instructional suggestion
but let's stick with maybe what we
wonder about what this is I'm King I
jumped us on the ladder for example
imagine an administrator pops into a
classroom and notices that there's lots
of students chatting at once but the
teacher is over in the corner paying
attention to just one student if the
administrator adds the interpretation
that the student is distracting the
teacher from his work and that the other
children are taking advantage of the
situation and just fooling around the
administrator might draw the conclusion
that the teacher has cost room
management problems and then put a
negative note in the teacher's file in
that example the administrator jumped
from her observation that multiple
students were talking at once and that
the teacher was only talking to one
student both of which were true facts
but she interpreted that the teacher was
distracted and that the students were
off task not taking the time to
investigate whether other
interpretations could have been equally
plausible for example maybe the teacher
was deliberately giving one-on-one
feedback to each student that day and
the rest of the students were supposed
to be engaged in small group discussion
by using the ladder of inference to help
you note when you're making inferences
you can catch yourself every time you
treat an interpretation as though it
were a fact because this discipline can
be so helpful this course will give you
lots of practice in starting low on the
ladder and making a conscious choice
whenever you want to climb up it for
each step of the data wise course you'll
have a chance to look at an artifact
from a school and make observations that
are grounded in the data a very helpful
way of sticking to evidence that data
wise schools use is a protocol called I
notice I wonder first we focus on
statements about what we notice these
statements should be as specific and
non-judgmental as possible then we
wonder about what we noticed these
wonderings start to climb up the ladder
to include interpretations of the data
but they're framed as questions since we
are less certain of them wonderings
allow us to ask meaningful questions
about the evidence while also providing
a space to let us acknowledge the
inferences that our minds may be jumping
to you will then have a chance to see
how members of the data wise team
collaboratively notice and wonder when
making sense of a wide range of data
sources this exercise will help you
cultivate the e
the ACE habits of mind a relentless
focus on evidence
[Music]